I don't think I need to go to therapy
anymore I think this is like really like
fixes everything I know about myself my
name is LJ ring and I'm a car follow G
expert apologies the study of
handwriting the study of handwriting can
be used to get a better idea of
somebody's personality and who they are
as a person at that moment in time so
it's very specific so yes your signature
will always change let's get some people
in here I don't know what I'm doing here
what am I doing here that's the real
question
print out your first and last name on
the small card and then sign your
signature the way to read portrait is
there type of person who will go ahead
and follow the rules very similar to how
children when they sign or do their
homework it's always portrait when you
put your name at the very top if someone
goes ahead and chooses landscape then
they're a type of person that's willing
to think outside the box
hello hi hi Zach I'm LJ that what I'm
hoping to do is just based off of your
signature tell you what I know about you
as a person in your personality at this
moment in time okay so let's look at
your signature reveals shall we no bud a
lot of angles though okay basically your
first name it associates with who you
are to people who have just first met
you your last name is really who you are
and who you were born to be you are you
do have a lot of angles and angles are
usually depict sarcasm oh you don't say
what you see is what you get you can get
a little sarcastic when you leave a
first impression you also always always
always make sure to leave it on a high
note you want to make sure that when it
comes down to it if someone were to ever
say oh yeah I met Jared the other day oh
my god he's so great isn't he really
friendly sweet didn't it even though you
will make a really big appearance or a
really big entrance you will sort of sit
there and just kind of scope and look
around really quick
I don't want to say judge the room but
you're definitely okay what I will also
say is your J is separated from your a
you already are skeptical about a person
you're about to me that's me or you know
there's just there's just that moment of
hesitation I'm gonna meet someone for
the first time and they kind of have the
crocus
all the letters are all connected but
when you first meet someone there's a
little bit of distance between your n
and your Y so which basically it's kind
of like hi I'm Neela and then you sit
and kind of wait for them to talk a
little bit more what is like based off
of my days that you know all of them the
first third of your last name or at
least the first three letters depict
your relationship with your friends
second is the depiction of the
relationship that you have with your
family and then the last one is who you
are as a person so your eyes supposed to
be towards the end of your last name but
if you notice your eye dot is over where
your friends are so your goals this is
you it usually depicts goals so where
you see yourself who you want to be all
that other stuff when it goes into the
last name the idea that your friends
have about your career hold more of an
importance than your family's idea of
where your career needs to be first
third of your last name so if I were to
take four letters and divide it into
three the first third is your
relationship with your friends and that
is a that's big obviously it is the
biggest part they have the biggest
impact on you damn that's mighty
accurate my friend you you judge
yourself a lot sometimes you can talk
yourself into a really bad mood sad
place where you're just all by yourself
I love that upswing on the very end of
the name is you're just like I get it
I'm drowning but at least I'm hydrated
you don't let your friends get away with
anything absolutely not
you want to make sure that you're there
for your friends because it feels like
there's nobody else telling them the
truth that's exactly where I'm at like
now
and you you made it sound like way worse
but you're like wow this guy in his JS
that's what I run that's [ __ ] insane
yeah I got goose bumps that was [ __ ]
on point I feel thanks geez good job
thank you you were I mean it's like kind
of wild because you were spot-on just
like with every single thing yeah this
is very spot-on
oh I wish it wasn't so spot-on just read
me like that oh that's [ __ ] up
you wrote it yeah
[Music]